Accessibility at Dudley Park Aquatic Centre
has been given a lift with the installation
of a new hoist and change table in the facilities
accessible changing rooms.
The $20,000 equipment is designed to allow
pool users with limited mobility to move more
easily between the shower equipment, toilet
and their wheelchair.
It means better accessibility to what's available
for everybody else, so if you want to come
for a swim, you can come for a swim.
The new motorised change table can also be
used for showering, it's height adjustable
and has a rail for safety.
Children have be known to have to be to changed
on the floor previously, but now we've got
the bed, they can go onto the bed and they've
got the safety rail to prevent them from falling.
We had a situation where those who had access
issues were having to change in a semi-public area
It just wasn't an equitable situation, so
providing this facility in an area that can
be closed off and become private is absolutely
essential in our view to equality of access.
The centre also has a poolside hydraulic chair
and a dedicated wet wheelchair which allows
wheelchair users to use ramp access to better
enjoy the pool.
Councillor Peter Allen says this is a result
of the council’s ongoing dedication towards
ensuring the region’s public facilities
are enjoyed by all residents.
For example we're looking at our camping grounds
in our district and wanting to ensure that
any review of those camping grounds deals
with access issues which might have been overlooked
in the past.
And Jill expects that the newly improved changing
room will see use of the pools increase from
those with accessibility requirements.
That would be the goal, to make it more accessible
for everybody, so everybody in our community
has the same access to the same facilities,
to do the same things.